[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
we break down week one of testimony in
the derrick chauvin trial
what fellow officers are saying about
the former minneapolis cop's use of
force
on george floyd if your knee is on a
person's neck
that can kill them our investigation
continues into the man
seen in the car with floyd on the day he
died could maurice hall be facing
potential charges
will he be forced to testify when you're
dealing with a world of drugs
you know you're not going to have mother
teresa walking up to the stand
plus how george floyd's family is giving
back to the local community
during the trial law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome to long crime daily everybody
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer
who's on assignment in minneapolis
and with us as always is terry austin
now the first week of testimony has
wrapped up in the derek
chauvin trial brian how's the
prosecution's case look so far
so far so good jesse but remember we're
missing the biggest part of this case
and that's the medical examiner's
testimony so far we've heard from
spark of life witnesses we've heard from
eyewitnesses who broke down
crying on the scene with that sense of
guilt that they couldn't do anything
for george floyd heard from his
girlfriend as i mentioned earlier
but in the last couple of days we also
heard from a lieutenant
and a shift sergeant who spoke about
both their actions on the scene
and the procedures and the lack of
procedures taken by derek chauvin
on that day it was very interesting we
took a break halfway through today
starting back next week that's what
we've seen so far jesse all right thanks
brian
now we know that a police supervisor was
called by a 911 dispatcher after
watching the officers kneel on floyd's
neck on the city's surveillance camera
the don't call me a snitch call that
supervisor can be heard on chauvin's
body cam video calling him directly
after that
2 30 here
[Music]
yeah i was just uh going to call and
have you come out to our
scene here
um not really but we just had to have to
hold the guy down he was uh
was uh going crazy wasn't going
coming off for the moment wouldn't go in
the back of the uh
squad he made a reference to shutting
off can you explain to the jury what
that was in reference to i probably
asked him if he had his camera on or off
since we're having a private
conversation
and that would be within policy within
the body-worn camera policy for him to
shut off during the
during that conversation is that right
yes did he tell you
uh whether he personally applied any
particular type of force
or restraint to mr floyd i don't believe
so
at one point during the supervisor's
testimony the jury was taken out for the
prosecution to proffer the witness
that's to lay the foundation for a very
important question
the jury was brought back in and the
supervisor was asked this
sir based on your review of the body
worn camera footage
do you have an opinion as to when the
restraint of mr floyd
should have ended in this encounter yes
what is it when mr floyd was no longer
offering up any resistance to the
officers they could have
entered the restraint and that was after
he was handcuffed and on the ground
and no longer resistant correct thank
you
defense attorney eric nelson was able to
get the supervisor to make a series of
concessions
on cross-examination would you agree
with the general prosper
premise that the use of force is not
necessarily attractive
yes sometimes officers have to do very
violent things agreed yes
it's a dangerous job correct
and in a force review there are certain
things that you're required to do
correct
yes that would include uh having a
conversation with the involved officer
right right that would involve
potentially having a conversation with
the suspect
upon whom force was used agreed yes
review of the body worn cameras right
yes review of any other evidence that
may exist such as
witness statements uh photographs
phone records whatever it may consist of
right
yes it's not a huge very thorough
investigation it's kind of a cursory
look
right correct and um
but there's more to it than simply
watching a body worn camera
right yes and you did not do a use of
force review in this case did you
no all right terry there was an
interesting moment when the defense
objected to the prosecution asking about
use of force
what exactly was that about and what was
plugger ultimately allowed to say
well jesse the prosecution was trying to
get officer pluto to answer whether he
believed the restraint or the use of
force
used against floyd was improper when
nelson objected the judge allowed
him to do of war dear as you mentioned
and ultimately the judge
said the prosecution could come back and
ask the limited question
of whether sergeant plusher thought the
restraint on floyd
should have ended and at that point cluj
said yes the restraint should have
ended once floyd was no longer resisting
so he got the point in
but not exactly the way the prosecution
wanted it
so brian if that's what the prosecution
is doing here
then what is the defense attempting to
do and were they successful
yeah they were successful i i would even
say it was an attempt that's masterful
lawyering right there by eric nelson
the facts really aren't on your side
from here from the uh
from the point of the view of this
officer saying yeah derek chovin should
not have done this
but the defense made the proper
objections and limited that testimony
thus taking the sting out of at least
this witness
to be able to go deeper into whether or
not derrick shoven should have left his
knee
on george floyd neck or taken it off i
think he also scored a lot of points
you heard some of them in the previous
clip where you're going to hear those
again
during the closing arguments where he
says hey policing's a dirty uh dirty job
sometimes it doesn't look so great but
you got to do what you got to do i think
it's really wise for eric nelson to go
that route
it's amazing to hear what the bystanders
had to say but now which we were
expecting the law enforcement experts
this is really what the case is about so
to hear it from their own mouths
it just changes the whole context of
this trial
all right still ahead on law and crime
daily the minneapolis police lieutenant
calling derrick chauvin's use of force
uncalled for and totally unnecessary
but first the man seen with george floyd
on the day he died
why police arrested him during jury
selection and much more on the
investigation into his criminal
background
[Music]
next
and welcome back everybody we're
learning more about the man who was in
george floyd's car with him the night he
died
law and crime's angenette levy has been
digging into the background of marie's
hall
and jeannette jesse maurice hall will
invoke his
fifth amendment privilege against
self-incrimination if called to testify
and we decided to look into why exactly
hall
may not want to take the stand
put your hand up let me get over here
sir no you're going to stay right there
for me
maurice hall was in the front passenger
seat of george floyd's suv when
minneapolis police approached on may
25th
2020. he'd also been in cup foods with
floyd where they both bought something
floyd's girlfriend testified that hall
is a drug dealer
are you familiar with maurice hall
yes and was maurice hall the person that
you and mr floyd
bought controlled substances from we had
hall has a long rap sheet in texas for
drug offenses and in minnesota
at the time of floyd's death he had
warrants out for his arrest for third
degree drug possession
and felony possession of a firearm what
we know is that mr hall is not a very
sympathetic figure and there is some
criminal liability and now he's taking
the fifth amendment
dave ehrenberg is the state's attorney
for palm beach county in florida
we asked him what criminal liability
hall faces
there are a number of crimes he could
have been charged with
from drug crimes to counterfeiting
maybe obstruction of justice there are a
bunch of things he'd be charged with and
so
he is clearly trying to save himself
it's not clear whether hall had
something to do with that counterfeit
twenty dollar bill
what is clear is hall is in custody in
hennepin county for violating a
protection order against a woman
he had pleaded guilty to trying to
strangle the mother of his child
while she was pregnant court records
show the woman was in the backseat of
hall's car
when he was pulled over for an expired
license on march 20
in the middle of jury selection in
chauvin's trial
does hall have any criminal liability in
floyd's death given the confrontation
with police
hall would only have criminal liability
in george floyd's death
if the drugs that he allegedly provided
george floyd
are what caused george floyd's death
when pulled over by police on march 20th
hall also had
another warrant out for his arrest out
of another county we're still working to
get
information on that case and what that
warrant pertains to
his attorney declined to comment when i
contacted her jesse
thanks ann janette you know brian what
is going on here what do you think is
really going on behind the scenes for
why he doesn't want to testify
yeah so jesse he's going to incriminate
himself
you better believe that eric nelson is
going to go into both his criminal
record
but also his actions on that day of may
25th 2020
i'm seeing just by eyeballing it that's
uh possession of a controlled substance
that's intend to sell uh again maybe if
they can make the connection that the
drugs
in his system as eric nelson is pointing
out actually killed
george floyd that's a homicide charge
and so all of those he would be able to
invoke his fifth amendment right
and so the prosecution got to think is
the juice worth the squeeze do i bother
putting him on the stand
when you can actually just have the
video and show everything that he would
testify to so i don't think they're
going to extend
any kind of courtesy to him to have him
testify you just asked the
million-dollar question i'll bring it to
terry
if hall doesn't end up testifying terry
you think the prosecution
really needed his testimony how valuable
is he well jesse that's a great question
no i don't think they needed him
at all i think they're better off
without his testimony
the jury would probably find that he's
not credible because
we know already from floyd's girlfriend
courtney ross
that he's a drug dealer and the jury
might think about that
and she even said that she never even
liked him so
what the prosecution would have tried to
establish
is the fact that floyd was
absolutely addicted to the opioids and
maybe they wanted to establish what the
scene looked like
but we already know from the girlfriend
that he was addicted to opioids and we
already know
from the other bystanders what the scene
looked like so i don't think the
prosecution
needs to call him at all
and jeanette is this really about hall
not george floyd's addiction
yeah you know george floyd obviously was
a drug addict
and that's not a fault of his that's a
problem that a lot of people in this
country are dealing with there are major
parts of this country that have been
in the throes of an opioid epidemic for
many years now and many people have
become
hooked on these things when they're
prescribed pain pills just like george
floyd was
and his girlfriend she testified to that
so this really
isn't about painting george floyd in in
a bad light
we just kind of want to show you why
maurice hall who he
was why he was there that day and why
maybe pleading the fifth
yeah hey listen if you can get another
person to explain another portion of the
story that's incredibly useful
in this kind of case and we're already
getting all different kinds of angles on
what happened that day
and afterwards and clearly before as
well well coming up here on long crime
daily
back into the courtroom for the derrick
chauvin trial
plus how george floyd's family is giving
back to the minneapolis community
during the trial their volunteer work
[Music]
next
the family for each side in the derek
shoven case gets only one
seat in the courtroom and members of
george floyd's family decided to take a
break from court coverage
and volunteered at his former employer
the salvation army
george floyd's sister bridget floyd is
seeing helping out at the food
distribution center
bridgette along with her family founded
the george floyd memorial foundation
to provide scholarships and give back to
the community we spoke to two of floyd's
cousins who
are also directors of the foundation
it's a labor of love if you will it's
kind of like anything that we can do
that can you know make sure people
he has a legacy of doing things that are
positive within the community
and and you know we've always been
people that wanted to give back that's
something
that he enjoyed doing working with the
youth in the community so a lot of the
programs are
touch on things that were important to
him
terry do you think creating the
foundation will help the family at all
with the healing process
yes it will absolutely help them with
the healing process i think it gives
them an opportunity
to give back to the community oftentimes
when you have
tragedies like this the families have a
hard time getting back into society and
doing
the everyday daily tasks i think by
volunteering for the salvation army
where floyd actually worked
i think that gives them an opportunity
to give back and all of the other
volunteer opportunities that they are
talking about
really gives them a purpose and they're
doing it all in honor
of his name so i think it's a win-win
it's a great opportunity
for both the community and the family
now brian it's my understanding you
spoke to rodney floyd george floyd's
youngest brother did that give you any
insight into the family
yeah it did so during the time that
charles mcmillan took
was on the stand and broke down the
court went into recess and everyone kind
of left for a minute
when i went and sat down outside rodney
floyd had sat down close to me and i saw
that he was struggling somewhat
i shared with him that i am roman
catholic as well i know there was a
vigil and a prayer
the week sorry the day before opening
statements and he told me that the
family is very religious
that they're leaving this trial in god's
hands and spoke about how prayer is
helping not only him
but his family get through this so it's
not surprising that the floyd family
is looking to giving back to the
community in any kind of way of service
to help in this time of need and hurt
yeah it's not just derek chovin it's not
just george floyd there are so many
more people who've been affected by this
and it's good that we can get an insight
it's particularly
to george floyd's family when we come
back one of the
top cops in the minneapolis police
department is speaking out against derek
chovin see as he arrived to the crime
scene and his letter
calling the cops actions a failure
[Music]
and welcome back everybody while we
cover the derek chauvin trial i also
want to tell you about another show
on the long crime network prime prime
this week we're talking about
michael draka who became the center of a
heated debate over self-defense
a verbal altercation in a florida
parking lot suddenly turned
deadly draco was charged with
manslaughter we're going to go through
this complicated issue with
draca's attorney and a florida
prosecutor it's draca's own
incredible interrogation tapes though
that lay out quite the story
i was standing like this fucking i was
hit from right here
the shoulder pulled in front of me and
then i was
i was on the ground uh so that time i
had to
put hand down to get a hand out from
underneath
as i come out i start drawing my weapon
as i start leveling up my weapon he
makes his next step
towards me and 21 football
so how does this all play out for draco
and what's the latest in this case
you're gonna have to tune in to law and
crime back now to the derek chauvin
trial where prosecutors called the head
of the minneapolis police homicide unit
who responded to the scene on the night
george floyd died
that lieutenant was one of 14 officers
who signed a letter
last summer condemning chauvin's actions
have you ever in all the years you've
been working for the minneapolis police
department
uh been trained to kneel on the neck of
someone who is handcuffed behind their
back in a prone position
no i haven't is that if that were done
would that be considered
force absolutely what level of force
might that be
that would be the top tier the deadly
force why
because of the fact that
um if if your knee is on a person's neck
that can kill him on cross defense
attorney eric nelson questioned him
about a use of force scenario when your
life
is in jeopardy you have never been
trained as a minneapolis police
officer to use a knee on the neck of a
suspect
that's correct you would agree however
that in a fight for your life
generally speaking in a fight for your
life
you as an officer are allowed to use
whatever force
is reasonable and necessary correct yes
and that can even involve improvisation
agreed
yes minneapolis police department policy
allows a police officer to use
whatever means or nest are available to
him to protect himself
and others right yes so if there's a
paint can
sitting on the table and someone is
attacking you can use that paint can as
a weapon
yes hmm all right brian
it seems that nelson's cross of
zimmerman might be setting the stage for
something
else what do you think that might be
yeah it's a very familiar strategy where
you're talking to the lieutenant
and getting brought as he said general
standards
practices as to what an officer can do
to protect himself
then he's juxtaposing that we heard him
also say that
well you haven't been on the street
since 1993
basically saying that well you're some
boss you don't work in the trenches
which i think is a very common thing
that a lot of people understand
we four may not understand that because
dan abrams is our boss and he
really knows what he's doing but the
common person may say hey i do my job my
boss doesn't really know what i do
and it's setting up for someone who was
actually there to testify to what went
down
now the other three officers won't
testify to that but maybe derrick trump
will take the stand and say
my boss doesn't really know what he's
talking about but i follow the general
things he's
he's saying and that's why i did what i
did wow
that would be incredible if he did that
now terry what did you think of
zimmerman's cross
i mean in general because he was a
strong witness for the state
yeah i agree but i think nelson did a
good job with the cross-examination of
lieutenant zimmerman and
in fact i think it was a master class on
cross-examination one of the things that
he did is
he asked specific questions to make his
points so for instance he said
do you need to look at the totality of
the situation to determine
the use of force and each of those
questions was
yes no yes no and he went through
every single point and basically if you
look at the transcript
of his questions and take out the
answers that's going to form the basis
of his summation
and he actually did it with other
witnesses
as well he did it with officer plunger
so i think that he
is establishing repetition he's doing
with each of the witnesses he's making
his points whether you agree with them
or not
and he'll probably do that on summation
so i think he's doing
as good a job as he can do with this
type of situation
terry real quick 20 seconds i mean he
basically said that
once a suspect's handcuffed they're
really no longer a threat did he extend
himself a little too far there terry
yeah a little bit but i think it was
cleaned up he said they weren't a threat
and then he tried to say yes i think
that
of course if you kicked somebody that
would be a threat but what he meant was
that it definitely
lowered the threat level well okay we
know where he stands against chauvin
but given that comment i don't know how
the jury might think about it there's a
lot more to cover in this case
everybody thanks for joining us here on
long crime daily we're going to see you
next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you